我想近這一個月來
我想很多人都關心這個
美國、以色列和伊朗的戰爭
一個牽動世界局勢的戰爭
今天我也想用這個作為一個開始
不過就從另外一個角度
我覺得戰爭是一個平台
你可以看到人在這方面的發明是很厲害的
在這次的戰爭裡面
你看到各樣不同的武器
不知道大家有沒有留意時事
在這個左上角
被稱為MOAB就是Mother of all bombs
就是常規武器裡面最厲害的一個炸彈
甚至投彈的時候
要用G170大力士運輸機的
因為太重太大
因為這個Mother of all bombs
是常規武器裡面最厲害的
如果你要提升那個戰力
你就要用這個非常規武器
比如說核彈等等
用到很盡了
旁邊那個就是鑽地彈
因為你知道伊朗有很多
那些地下的導彈城
地下的核設施
投射這些鑽地彈的就是這個B2轟炸機
左手邊下面那張就是
那個是一個魚雷
一個Mk 48超重的魚雷
我想你都還記得在印度洋
有一艘伊朗的護衛艦
在印度演習完
就回伊朗
在途中被美國的潛艇擊沉
其實這艘護衛艦不是大格
也不是很先進的
其實打它可以用飛彈都可以的
有時候用飛彈
你還會給它時間能夠逃生
但是它們竟然用到這個魚雷
你看見在YouTube裡面
你可以看見很快就沉了
當時蘭卡
當時蘭卡的舊船艦去到的時候
其實船已經沉了
為什麼會用到超重魚雷去對付它呢
聽說當日在美國的潛艇
那艘叫洛杉磯級的潛艇
有兩個澳洲的海軍人員接受訓練
你知道澳洲就買了美國的核潛艇
也都
某程度就默許了
如果太平洋第一島鏈有什麼事
澳洲就會出兵
所以其實當日在潛艇裡面
應該也是一個實戰訓練來的
而旁邊那個
都很厲害
那個叫石密彈
就是說它威脅
炸伊朗的發電廠的
那你發覺不是傷害民生的那些東西
因為他們發覺有一個現象就是
在一些鄉村、在一些人口少的地方
大概用電量很高
很可能就是背後有一些核設施
又或者有一些軍事設施
所以他們為什麼美國要求
要脅說要炸這個發電廠
但是如果炸了發電廠就不得了
影響很多人、影響民生
這個石密彈是什麼呢
就是它一投入的時候
那些石密本身令到有很多的短路發生
就令到它輸不了電
但是那個發電廠
和那些發電設施是沒有被摧毀的
那你可以看到是不是很厲害
其實這些的戰爭科技
又例如美國的無人機
Lucas無人機
另外無人快艇、無人艇
你看到左下角有一個叫做star shield
其實這個也是space X的
Starlink是為民用的
Star shield是為軍用的
所以你發覺如果拆開那些無人機的機頭
有一些接收器的
那就是那些star shield的導航來的
另外在這個右手邊的上角
那個就是激光炮
其實近年由2023年開始
他們很流行的一件事
就是所謂的飽和攻擊
用一些很便宜的武器
比如說無人機
或者一些很便宜的導彈
這樣呢
你那個導彈是更加貴的
我想你都聽過就是1比100
就是說那個導彈的價值
是那個無人機的100倍
即是人家出事有
點都點乾你了
所以你發覺在這次裡面
你看到很多很便宜的
這樣
從這些武器裡面
你可以看到就是
那個科技相當先進
曾經有人說
他說什麼呢
人發明的武器
從來都沒有在戰場上不被應用的
而事實上在戰爭歷史裡面
武器可以說是有幾次的
有三次的革命的發展的
那我就很想用這個叫做骨幹講一下
如果有人問你
在歷史裡面
最大的帝國是哪一個呢
不知道你會不會說是蒙古帝國
正確的
因為在歐亞一大片的裡面
蒙古帝國橫跨歐亞大陸是很大片的
為什麼他們能夠這麼厲害呢
蒙古最厲害的就是它的騎兵
我覺得這幅畫裡面
當我找到這幅畫
我覺得這幅畫的人
他都相當認識蒙古的騎兵
為什麼呢
因為蒙古兵其中一個厲害的就是它的弓
那個弓有名的叫反曲弓
你看到那個弓兩邊是不是勾出來
比起當時的十三世紀
那些弓強成三、四倍的
近距離可以射穿盔甲的
另外還有一樣東西就是
馬燈
上馬的時候那個腳踏
那個馬燈
雖然馬燈不是蒙古人發明的
但是馬燈的功用
蒙古就將它發揮到極致
為什麼呢
因為由於馬燈的緣故
那個騎馬的人能夠站在馬步上
而他可以在360度去射箭
去壓制著對方
正因為有馬燈有這麼強的弓
所以有一招很出名的就是回馬箭
你不要以為它敗走你追著它
它轉頭就可以拿你命了
所以你看見蒙古在十三世紀
橫掃沒有人能夠去打
第一次的
武器的革命是什麼呢
就是人們用火藥
將火藥應用在軍事上面
那就出現了這個火槍
另外就是火炮
所以如果有人問你
最大的帝國其實
算面積不是蒙古
算面積
你都很熟悉的
就是什麼呢
就是入不落帝國
就是大英帝國
在歷史中
算面積最大的就是大英帝國
這個就是第一次的
在戰爭上
武器上的革命
如果有人跟你說
三分熟、五分熟
或者全熟
你會想起什麼呢
可能你會想起
是不是教人煎牛扒呢
其實這個是一個jogging來的
是一個term來的
就是某國、某大國
即美國
美國一旦遇到核攻擊
所作出的反應的一個選項來的
到底三分熟、五分熟
還是全熟呢
其實講的不是牛扒
而是地球
即如果一旦受到攻擊
受到核攻擊
作出的反應
到底是同歸於盡呢
還是怎樣的回應呢
所以第二個革命
在武器史上
就是核子彈的發明
你知道核子彈發明了之後
沒有多久就投了兩顆在日本
而美國相當強
到現在都是
核子彈呢
我覺得都還有兩樣東西是很特別的
第一就是什麼呢
就是你要有這個核燃料
而這些核燃料呢
基本上不是那麼容易得到的
譬如現在伊朗呢
它很想成為
即擁有核武的國家
但是要提煉
要得到這些的核燃料
不是那麼容易的
再加上在國際上面
有所謂核不擴散條約
所以
從1945年到現在
其實都只有十個國家
是擁有核子的武器的
即核子的能力的
這樣
不過一提
你發覺
最後那兩個
我都打了一年份
不知道你看不看得到
最後那兩個成為核國家的
最後那個就是北韓
2006年
接著再上一個就是
巴基斯坦
今天我們的聚會
有一個題目
有個名字叫做
機械殺手
或者叫做殺手機械人
其實機械人在生活上面
在很多方面已經影響到大家了
其實
譬如這裡
你看見
左上角那個就是Vamo
有沒有搭過你們那邊
譬如你在LA downtown
你很快會見到的
就是那些無人駕駛的的士
Vamo很容易認的
車頂、台兩邊
兩邊很多感應器的
另外旁邊那個就是
即是Shake Shack的那些
送這個文件
送這些食物的機械人
有些機械人就
譬如這個Optimus
就是Tesla的
最近剛剛有個新聞就是
它現在開始坐這個Counter
譬如在LA這裡有一個地方
叫做Diamond Bar
它的CDH就是
機械人
你一靠近它
它就會問你
它能夠幫到你什麼
這樣
那些機械人也都幫忙
這個執法
這樣的
早幾天我就見到這輛車
不知道你有沒有留意這些科技
叫做Cybercap
其實Waymo是Google的
而Cybercap就是Tesla的
我就不其而問一問題
既然都不是什麼特別
就是無人駕駛的的士
這個Cybercap有什麼特別呢?
有沒有留意?
我在街上看到他試車
這個就是特別之處了
就是沒有軚盤的
也沒有腳掣的
那如果是所謂的龍飛船
SpaceX 那些接人去國際太空站的飛船
其實就是這樣的了
你上船只有一個手機在那裡
不是 只有一個手機在那裡
那就連軚盤都沒有的
所以不知道有什麼事都不知道怎麼辦
今天我們講殺手機械人
Killer Robot 其實這個是一個俗稱來的
它的學名其實是什麼呢?
就是一個Litho Autonomous Weapon
就是致命的、自主的武器
顧名思義就是一個武器
不過它有兩個要素
第一就是它配備致命的武器
第二樣東西是什麼呢?它是自主的
一會兒我們會講到
所以殺手機器人其實它就是具備這兩個特點
第一它有致命的武器 第二就是它自主
那不知道你心目中殺手機器人是怎麼樣的呢?
會不會是這樣的呢?
曾幾何時有些電影
《Terminator》或者《Robocop》
你都見到類似的
但是這些都是拍片
近似一些現實的就是比如《Big Dog》
在上面有一支槍
又或者有一些履帶的機械人
那你說 不是的 不是的
我在電視上看到那些機械人
那些殺手機械人不是這樣的
是這樣的
我在電視上
最近春晚我才見過
這些殺手機械人
懂得打聚拳的
其實人形的機械人
就未必最有優勢的
因為你兩隻腳
一定是不會夠四隻腳跑得快的
另外加上如果地形是凹凸的
另外一個方面
我想你都不夠那些你帶車
走得夠穩妥的
其實除了伊朗戰爭之外
還有一場戰爭
北京、北角已經打了四年多了
就是俄羅斯烏克蘭的戰爭
在上年裏面
就曾經有這樣的一幕的
就是有一些俄羅斯的軍人
他就投降了
他就向一些部隊投降
但是那些部隊
都是新人的
全部是機械人來的
不知道你有沒有留意這個新聞
我在YouTube裏面看到
我不知道你還找不找得到
當時是怎樣呢
當時有架無人機
烏克蘭的無人機
飛過上去
在戰壕上面
就發現有些俄羅斯的士兵
有些士兵向那個無人機開槍
接著沒多久
就有一架戰車
看到的
螢幕上面
右邊的下面那個
其實那架車是什麼呢
其實那架車是炸彈來的
四個輪子
炸彈
駛到戰爭那裏
就想一鑊熟的
但是那些俄羅斯的士兵看到這樣
就扯白旗
就表示投降
接著那架有機槍的戰車
就出現了
就將他們繳鞋
和將他們押回去這個俘虜營
這樣
你覺得這樣都行嗎
其實如果你留意一下新聞
你就知道這四年裏面
使烏克蘭成為一個
在軍事上都是一個強國
特別是什麼呢
就是那些無人機的系統
譬如無人的飛機
無人的車
無人的戰車
無人的艦艇
無人的艦艇都很出名的
因為為什麼呢
因為它壓制著黑海艦隊的
俄羅斯的黑海艦隊
這樣
而控制這些的無人的機械的時候
通常就是用一個叫做
First person view
即是說第一身的視覺
即是說那架飛機看到的東西
那個鏡頭看到的東西
就是你看到的東西了
就好像畫面你見到
那個控制的人
他就是這樣了
他看到的就是
那個無人機鏡頭裏面
拍攝到的情況了
這樣
從2024年的年尾開始
在烏克蘭的戰場裏面
他們就已經開始了
實行這個所謂協同作戰
即是一個士兵、一個單兵
他不單止是控制那些陸上的戰車
他也都可以同時控制
這個空中的那些無人機
所以有監察
剛才那個例子
他發現那些的俄兵
接著就可以調動一架炸彈車
去到中間
簽了的
那你可以看到
就是協同作戰
使他一個單兵
能夠控制這個海洛空的
無人的那些武器
再加上就是
人工智能在這幾年裏面
在戰場上的發展
就令到它是
即是那個果效更加厲害
即是用機械人的果效
因為為什麼呢
因為人工智能
可以將大量偵測到的
那些的資料
海量的資料
能夠消化
能夠分析
從而判斷到戰場的情況
繼而提供一些的選項
這樣
所以你有沒有留意
近這幾個月
你會發覺美軍是不是很厲害
比如捉馬杜羅這樣
一晚幾個小時
竟然就捉到
其實在中南美洲
委內瑞丹算是一個軍事強國來的
但是一捉就捉到了
明天我舉多個例子
你會了解
不知道大家有沒有看過這齣戲
這齣戲叫做《Zero Dark Thirty》
有些人誤以為
如果你要看戰爭片
十大其中一齣就是這樣
《Zero Dark Thirty》是什麼呢
中文我想你很熟了
通常那些人
那些軍事行動
他們就會選擇12點鐘至3點
因為《生理時鐘》告訴我們
大部分的人12點鐘至3點
就是他最脆弱的
最睏睡的時候
所以《Zero Dark Thirty》
就是說12點半
即5時30分的行動的意思
其中有這樣的一幕
話說這個中央情報局的
那個呂探
找到這個賓埃登
藏在巴基斯坦
但是就一直上級
就沒有行動了
為什麼呢
因為他怕引起外交風波
他就經常問
到底有多少城肯定
賓埃登是在那裡
在那個大宅那裡呢
那這個女情報局
就每一天去到上司門口
就寫下了
比如今天就寫下21天
找到這個大宅已經21天了
還沒有行動
一直去到159天
即四個多月
都沒有行動
最後才落取
這樣
而我想這次的
伊朗戰爭裡面
我覺得最
嚇人的是第一天
是不是
第一天就已經斬殺了這個
哈梅內伊了
不僅如此
在第一天裡面已經
殺了48個高級的將領
和一些重要的領袖
很厲害
為什麼他能夠這樣做到呢
除了武器精準之外
所以你看見
左手邊的上面
哈梅內伊的住宅
是不是很精準打擊
那棟樓就塌了
還有幾個洞
幾個洞是很深的
因為他用了
鑽地彈那一類
而附近的那些
樓宇
是沒有被摧毀的
這樣
其實就是什麼呢
就是他利用很多的監察
比如馬路的那些鏡頭
利用很多監察
利用人工智能去分析
將所有的目標人物
已經到場了
接著就決定用什麼時候
是不是把這個時候去出擊呢
還有當出擊的時候
用什麼武器呢
比如說藍爪
你也留意到有聽過
就是所謂用這個
Blue spiral
藍爪 藍麻爪
這個武器是很特別的
為什麼呢
因為一般的飛彈
一發射就向前的
但是它是向上的
它就衝出去這個大氣的邊緣
在太空的邊緣
為什麼是這樣呢
第一就是在太空邊緣阻力少
就是說它能夠射的射程更加遠
它回到地面的時候
進入這個大氣層的時候
它俯衝下來
那個速度快
攔截的機會就少了
你明白嗎
其實還有一個原因的
因為你看見
這個是戰爭第一天
戰爭的初期
其實你都不知道伊朗的防空系統
被鎮壓被摧毀了多少
所以它就是針對這件事
來選擇這個武器
因為你知道
你知道雷達無論你外面怎麼看
它裡面都有一個
天線是360度旋轉
其實原理就是這麼簡單
就是你發射一些
發射一些信號上去
即出去 然後它遇到些什麼
就回到前面
那你就知道前面的事情了
那是不是360度
但是大部分的雷達都有一個盲點
那個盲點是什麼
就是它的天頂
即它的頭頂
你會像鑊高頭那樣掃的
明白嗎
所以這個南馬竹有一個特點就是
它正正就在天頂那裡
在你頭頂
就攻下來
所以為什麼
開戰第一天
我想給你看見的是什麼呢
無論那些情報的分析
那些時間的把握
還有那些武器的運作
其實都是
經過人工智能的
消化而作出決定
所以那個成績是
很顯然的
這樣
好了
面對著這些
無人的武器
其實都有對策的
那這裡這一張
大家看到沒有
是什麼
你覺得這個城
這個城市
好像是不是有一層蜘蛛網在上面
那這個就是
烏克蘭東部的一個
城鎮的情況來的
那些是什麼來的呢
這樣
其實就是當一個無人機
它放了上天空的時候
它就是透過這個
電波
和這個
控制員
保持聯絡的
怎樣對付它呢
發一些的
即是說
一些的電子的干擾系統
那你一旦失去了聯絡
那就控制不了了
你明白嗎
那怎麼解決這個問題呢
它就是用光纖
用一些的
Fiber optic
用一些光纖
把無人機就連絡上去了
這樣它是不受電波干擾的
而透過
光纖一樣可以傳送
第一就是控制到那個無人機
另外就是傳送到那個景象
你仍然可以用第一聲音
去控制它
你明白我的意思嗎
那而那些的光纖
是很長的 幾十里
每一次都幾十里
如果毀滅了目標之後
那些光纖就留在戰場上面
所以久而久之
整個戰場就像蜘蛛網一樣
你看到那些光纖
就是這樣
如果你知道光纖的性質
不容易斷的
不過你可以想像到
當時的那個光纖
它是相當的問題
除了在戰場上
遺留了這麼多光纖之外
另外就是
多長都是幾十里
這樣
怎樣能夠解決這個問題呢
怎樣能夠解決這個
電波干擾的問題呢
這樣
那就
在幾個星期之前
在這個
《衛星》的雜誌裡面
就有一篇報道
這個人寫的其實是很出名的
他是一個四星上將來的
也都是CIA的
前局長
他就寫了一篇文章
講到就是自主戰場
什麼意思呢
他就說
其實最後打贏一場仗
不在乎那個國家
他擁有多少
無人機
多少無人武器
而是在乎
那些無人的武器
是怎樣決策的
如果當你發現了對方
而到開火之前
是仍然要人呢
要士兵呢
按那個攻擊制的時候
你這個操作
你這個反應已經太慢了
你明白我的意思嗎
啊
所以你看見
其實現在烏克蘭
左邊那個interceptor
就是烏克蘭研發出來的
也都幫助這個海灣國家
對付伊朗的那些無人機
右手邊那個就是
美國發明的
那些無人機
那這個無人機的特點是什麼呢
第一就是它是AI導航的
它的pilot是AI的
就是說
當你放它上去的時候
你就給了它一個任務
它就會執行這個任務了
當你放它上去空中的時候
它們都期望什麼呢
就是很快就失去聯絡了
因為有干擾嘛
但是你給了一個指令它
它就會執行了
它怎麼樣呢
它就會自動尋找目標
然後將它擊落
啊
以後這幾個情況之下
它可能會發生的
第一就是什麼呢
就是它找的目標呢
它已經被摧毀了
它就會安全的回航
又或者什麼呢
當它的目標被摧毀之後
它找另一個目標
它自己執行的
找另一個目標
然後去摧毀它
又或者什麼呢
又或者你再一次聯絡上這個無人機
改變它
或者給它另外一個指令
明白什麼意思嗎
簡單來說你一旦放了它上空中
它就自我自滅了
剛才唱歌的時候
我有個感覺的
因為主祂曾經救我們
祂仍要救我們
祂已經救我們脫離罪惡
祂也要救我們脫離災難
而先講到將來的災難
其中一樣東西就是
死很多人
特別是指著兩個時候
第一個時候就是
結開
印的時候
結開頭那幾印的時候
就像這個說的
他說結開第四印的時候
我聽到第四個活物就說
你來
我就觀看
見到有一匹灰馬
其實在馬上有個名叫死
陰虎隨著它
有權柄賜給它
可以用刀劍
饑荒瘟疫
野獸殺害地上
四分之一的人
之前它有三匹馬的
有一匹白馬、一匹紅馬、一匹黑馬
其實就是回應
之前那裡的那匹紅馬
就是刀劍 即是打仗
那匹黑馬是甚麼呢
就是饑荒
饑荒
亦都有瘟疫
不知道
我覺得這些瘟疫
有可能是
與軍事有些關係都未定
譬如現在你看見
例如COVID-19
一直以來
有些人
不想人追查那個源頭
但是
亦都有不少的
證據顯示
是很可能來自實驗室
這樣
你知道
常規武器 剛才我們講過一些
非常規武器除了核彈之外
另外就有生化武器
這樣
這個講到這裡
用刀劍饑荒瘟疫
野獸殺了地上四分之一人
現在全世界八十幾億人
死了四分之一知道甚麼
死了二十億人
中國十三億
美國三億多
只要說中美的人搭上去
都不夠填這條數
你明白嗎
這樣
為甚麼會死這麼多人
其實聖經也都講到
那場仗
有一個很厲害的火
譬如三分之一的地燒了
所有的青草燒了
三分之一的海
海洋受打擊
三分之一的日月星辰
我相信就不是太陽月亮
有甚麼問題
而是大氣層
大氣層出了狀況
受影響
甚麼會令到世界
三分之一的地
三分之一的海
三分之一的大氣受影響呢
可能就是跟核戰有關
在下個星期裏面
我們也會
講到這方面多一些
因為為甚麼呢
因為你可能會覺得
聖經是神的話
但聖經很古老
既然聖經這麼古老
它怎樣講到這些
現代才有的名詞呢
現代才有的狀況
其實都能夠表達到的
我們這方面
我們下一次可以講
講得多一些
但起碼你知道
在一月二月的時候
是不是美國還在講一個話題
就是想拿這個格陵蘭
拿這個格陵蘭
完成它那個
金窮頂的防禦計劃
可能有些人覺得
這些核彈是由東向西飛
由西向東飛
但你有沒有想過
其實它可以向北飛
橫跨這個
北極的
它的航道是更加短的
比如現在有些航線
飛機的航線
都是飛越北極的
其實這樣
所以這個就是
牽涉到
核子武器的形容了
最近都多了
很多這樣的戲的
關乎到核戰
核彈的攔截這些
再回應那句
人
發明的武器
從來都沒有不用的
而現在的
核彈
是比起當日的
廣島長崎的
威力是千倍以上
這樣
好了
剛才你說的
殺手機械人又是什麼呢
在聖經裏面
啟稍第九章有這樣的
一個描述
就說到有幾個天使
吹號 有七個天使吹號
第六個天使吹號的時候
他說有聲音
從神面前
神的面前
金壇四角就出來了
說什麼呢
他說要將被綑綁在
幼法拉底河的四個
天使者釋放出來
那四個使者就被釋放了
他們原來準備好
到某年某月某日某時
要殺人的
三分之一
馬君有二萬萬
他的數目我聽見了
第二道
說到死很多人
就是這裏
殺人的三分之一
如果按剛才這樣計
先是那四匹馬
死了四分之一人
全世界只剩下六十億人
死了四十億
六十億裏面再死三分之一
又死了二十億
去到這裏的時候
全世界已經
沒了一半人了
我這樣跟你說
其實這個時候是幾時呢
這個時候就是七年災難的一半的時候
即是
末後的災難都還沒發生
即是後三年半都還沒發生
所以說到最後
最後那三年半呢
聖經怎麼說呢
如果不是為了選民
為了以色列人的緣故
減少這些日子
所有有血氣的都不流去全流
其實前面的日子的災難
那個殺傷人的情況是很嚴重的
而剛才我們講的那四個印呢
就是七年災難的開始沒有多久
白馬之後而發生的
而這裏呢
這個第六位天使吹號
就是什麼呢
我可以這樣講就是
經過了那四匹馬之後
到後來有一個的
敵基督
即是獸的國出現
要有人拜祂
而對付異己
它是殺鹿來的
對付異己是殺鹿來的
那在這一次裏面呢
你發覺除了說殺人的三分之一
死很多人之外呢
還有兩個特點很特別的
第一就是你發覺它是某年某月
某日某時
很有趣的
它沒有說那些兵在哪裡來
要去哪裡打什麼仗
很多人就將它混淆了
即是跟其它的哈密吉多頓
或者其它的混淆了
其實不是的
你看清楚
它已經寫得有相當的暗示
比如它說什麼呢
它說是源於
幼法拉底河的四個使者被釋放
即是跟靈界有些關係的
而你知道幼法拉底河
就是現在的伊拉克
也是以前的巴比倫的地方來的
即是回到最初那個反叛的地方
這樣
而你發覺它是什麼呢
它說某年某月某日某時
殺人的三分之一
你看不看得見呢
其實不像一場仗來的
只是執行一個指令似的
最近Donald Trump
有一次全國演講了
幾天前
他就這樣說
他說其實在近代的歷史裡面
從來沒有一場戰爭是打一天的
現在的伊朗戰爭
都打了三十多天 整個月了
近代的戰爭
從來都沒有打一天半天的
何況還是某日某時的
所以你覺得
像不像執行一個指令
如果要找對象
執行指令要找對象
很容易的
譬如你現在看到
最近有個新聞就是
Facebook、Meta
或者其他有些
被法庭罰他
說他用一些的 algorithm
用一些的算式
去知道那些人
喜歡什麼東西
供一些東西給他看
讓他上癮
其實用這些信息來看
就可以知道你平時
你上網是怎麼樣的情況
就知道你大約是什麼樣的人
比如你喜歡看什麼
你個人的取向
政治的取向
各方面是怎麼樣
那就很容易分辨到
那些對象是怎麼樣的
另外一件事一提
他說馬軍有二萬萬
即是二億
其實現在全世界哪裏有一個國家
他有二億軍隊
沒有
但是呢
如果你說
剛才說的那些
機械人
殺手機械人
如果要有都不是難的
為什麼呢
因為二億
但是他是不是要殺三分一
三分一有二十億
那一個對十個而已
你明白嗎
所以絕對有這樣的可能
而那些馬軍是怎麼樣的呢
這樣
他在異象中
見到那些騎馬的
空前有甲
有火
有甲如火
又有紫馬路和硫磺
馬的頭好像獅子頭
好像獅子頭
我知道大家中午現在肚子餓了
這個獅子頭就不是講上海館那些
有火有煙有硫磺
從馬的口中出來
這三樣東西
就殺人的三分之一
馬的能力除了在口外
也在尾巴
我不知道是什麼
當日約翰他見到的就是這樣
這樣
我自己覺得
環顧現在發展的情況
當然今次的美國、以色列、伊朗的戰爭
還有很多啟發的
在政治上
比如對於歐洲
對於北約
另外對於以色列
在中東的位置
這些
留待日後有機會再講
但是在武器上面
你可以看到的是什麼呢
其實美國的經濟
美國的科技
美國的軍事是相當強
我覺得如果要對付美國
似乎只有一樣東西
就是核武
而當美國
和相對的勢力
一起step down的時候
你發覺剩下來的
很可能的勢力就不多
可能就是歐洲
明白嗎
而到時有一個的
敵對
敵基督的國
就會出現了
要人拜他 不拜他就要死了
這個就是剛才講的第六個情況
那我覺得
武器已經可以說是
你可以看到這些的苗頭
到底前面
會怎麼樣呢
今天我就
嘗試用這個
武器方面跟大家
講一下這場戰爭
下一個禮拜
我們就會講一下
到底前面會怎麼樣呢
那就不是時時分析的
那就在聖經裡面
它怎麼講前面會發生些什麼呢
那我們下個禮拜
才再見吧 好嗎
那我今天就講到這裏